[Musica]
[Applauso]
buon pomeriggio
sono vent'anni che non mi drogo più
di lavoro
e vi racconta oggi due metà due parti
della della mia vita che sono molto
importanti che sono molto
rappresentative
la storia parte del 1983 nel profondo
nord est io finisco il militare e entro
in questa azienda entro dalla porta di
servizio come garzone di bottega
fattorino magazziniere usate quel
termine che che più gli è congeniale e
cominciò a lavorare dopo però comincia
già a ragionare nella capitalizzazione
della mia vita ho dentro un fuoco e
voglio sviluppare la mia carriera
professionale
dopo un po di vento venditore 22 23 25
anni diventò direttore commerciale
a 25 anni succede l'imponderabile
alle ore 10 del luglio 10 luglio del
ricevo una telefonata
muore il fondatore di questa impresa
senza figli
in quel momento
in quel momento in cui mi sembrava che
tutta tutto mi crollasse addosso ho
capito che c'era una grande opportunità
per me mi faccio avanti
chiedo di acquistare l'azienda senza
soldi senza possibilità
chiedo di acquistarla chiedono l'impegno
a trovare i soldi tramite un'operazione
finanziaria che si chiama invio
management buyout dio con altri colleghi
compriamo
l'azienda per cui lavoravamo a 27 anni
diventò
amministratore delegato di questa
azienda sempre con grande voglia di fare
con una grande avevo accantonato la
parte goliardica della mia vita avevo
capito che se non mi realizza voli non
mi sarei realizzato più facciamo una
scalata incredibile prima 10.000 poi 20
milioni poi 30 milioni poi 40 milioni e
via dicendo
e arriviamo al 2004 2005
azienda di successo
storie di successo però io ero arrivato
a 100 e 8 kg
ero arrivato ad una situazione fisica
veramente veramente difficile
ero stato ricoverato due volte per il
ringo spasmo da ringo starr ma succede
quando tu non respiri più nuove spiri
più e ti ricovero all'ospedale ti fanno
delle iniezioni di adrenalina
sottocutanea per gli abilitati mi sono
arrivato a pochi centimetri da quella da
quel burrone di diciamo
diabete e quindi lì ho capito che non
poteva esistere un uomo vincitore
professionalmente è un uomo che aveva
ridotto la sua vita personale lumicino e
ho cominciato elaborare il progetto di
cui oggi vi parlo per riassestare le
cose e cosa ho fatto ho fatto una cosa
che se prendete nota potrebbe essere
esservi utile per tutto per tutta la
vita che fate per qualsiasi tipo di
mansione che abbiate per qualsiasi punto
in cui siete della vostra vita
innanzitutto diviso la vita in ruoli ho
diviso la vita in ruoli privati perché
tutti noi abbiamo un ruolo privato io
sono compagno sono figlio sono fratello
sono amico e ruoli professionali
nei ruoli professionali
troviamo la presidenza del mio gruppo
troviamo il fondatore di una di una
onlus troviamo il fondatore di una
community cofondatori nei commenti ho
diviso questa mia esistenza
i ruoli 10 ruoli e ho cominciato a
fissare degli obiettivi per ciascun
ruolo le sollecitazioni che abbiamo oggi
nella nostra vita ci portano verso
quello che vogliono gli altri
noi dobbiamo andare verso quello che
vogliamo noi per cui verso quello che la
nostra
azione personale il successo non ce lo
devono dire gli altri lo dobbiamo
decidere noi ho cominciato a descrivervi
ruoli e sui ruoli ho messo dentro ogni
ruolo tre obiettivi nel ruolo privato
del ruolo fisico ho messo dentro la
glicemia deve essere a 100 il peso deve
essere 90 kg e devo avere questo valore
è tenuto a minasi nel ruolo
professionale ho detto per la mia
fondazione devo trovare 200 benefattori
all'anno per la community devono trovare
aiutare gli imprenditori una volta che
ho fatto questi due palinsesti cioè i
ruoli e gli obiettivi la mia vita ha
cominciato a fare così
nel senso che mi sentivo molto più un
certo numero di ore settimanali
un certo numero di weekend fuori
staccare completamente un certo numero
di ore disintossicati da questo è tutta
te e ho cominciato a capire quello su
cui dovevo focalizzarmi e più facevo
questo è più era soddisfatto poi ho
fatto il terzo anello che è quello di
mettere a terra gli obiettivi cioè
dividere scomporre ogni obiettivo in
azioni pratiche di tutti i giorni e
sulle attività pratiche di tutti i
giorni il 70 per cento del mio tempo
dedicato a queste attività operative e
il 30 per cento random imprevisti o
quello che capita
ecco ho cominciato a essere più
equilibrato ho cominciato a calare di
peso ho cominciato a migliorare
fisicamente ha cominciato a trasformare
il mio corpo da acido alcalino ho
cominciato a migliorare sensibilmente
visibilmente energeticamente questo è un
aspetto che mi ha dato molto equilibrio
dopo ho pensato un'altra cosa ha detto
voglio passare dalla quantità prima
lavoravo sempre 3 euro alla settimana
staccavo alla qualità professionalmente
quindi a livello di vita generale avevo
riequilibrato professionalmente come
posso essere più efficace e loro creato
quattro strumenti che ancora oggi
sono proprio il palinsesto totale nella
parte operativa
ho creato ha solo dato nella parte
operativa
ho creato questi quattro strumenti e
sono partito per primo i teatri di
guerra ciascuno di noi ha
i teatri di guerra sono i fronti in cui
noi siamo impegnati
la vita è una guerra oggi e noi dobbiamo
essere pronti e sapere bene quali sono i
nostri teatri di guerra non quelli degli
altri nel mio caso ne ho venti quelli
sono io voglio focalizzarmi ii e quelli
sono proprio il palinsesto principale
della parte professionale
altro strumento la lista dei focus io
non voglio andare dietro alle cose che
gli altri mi seguono vogliono vendermi e
vogliono tirare tirarmi addosso io
volevo andare dietro i miei focus lista
dei focus sotto l'arco visivo ogni
giorno arrivò metto il mio computer di
franco tutte le scrivanie in cui lavoro
ho fatto mettere un plexigas metto sotto
nei focus quelli sono le cose che devo
fare per primo quando è il massimo
dell'energia psichica quindi teatri di
guerra liste di focus il terzo strumento
sono gli elementi gli elementi sono il
controllo dei numeri la vita è fatta nei
teatri di guerra è fatta dai numeri è
fatta dei capi ai fratelli cruscotti
chiamiamolo come vogliamo noi dobbiamo
misurare ciò che facciamo la vita random
un imprenditore o una persona un
professionista non la può fare quindi
teatri di guerra list di focus
numeri con queste tre cose qua la mia
area
professionale ha aumentato la
focalizzazione e diminuito il tempo
perché alle 8 a smetto alle 7 a smetto
perché ho finito le mie cose finito mi
mancano ultima cosa
tutti noi abbiamo bisogno di tante volte
siamo giorni ha bisogno di benzina di
carburante il quarto strumento sono gli
scopi
gli scopi della nostra vita sono il
carburante green verde ma solo il
carburante di tutto quello che facciamo
io tracciati 7 e quelli sono in cima a
tutto voglio lasciare questo segno qua
non voglio cambiare il mondo non voglio
andare in politica non voglio andare lo
sport ma per quegli scopi io ho deciso
di aiutare 10 mila piccoli e medi
imprenditori a risolvere i loro problemi
ho deciso di aiutare 100.000 bambini ad
avere l'educazione nel mondo
ho deciso ad aiutare 100 imprenditori
falliti a rimettersi in sesto nella loro
vita a riprendere in mano la radina loro
vita non cambierà il mondo ma per questi
il mondo lo cambio e quindi con il
teatro di guerra con la lista dei focus
con i numeri e con gli scopi o veramente
ma veramente tutto sotto mano dal punto
di vista professionale
questo
unito ai ruoli agli obiettivi e
l'attività operative sono un cruscotto
incredibile al punto che
vorrei lanciargli una sfida e è una
sfida molto io sono un uomo pratico
quindi voglio lanciare le sfide pratiche
voglio che questo ted rappresenti per
voi un momento di cambiamento
voglio che si accende una lampadina e
che poi questa lampadina voi la
sviluppate e andate a illuminare tutto
quello che volete diventare e allora vi
dico
perché
non accettate la sfida di diventare i
registi attori protagonisti del film
della vostra vita perché noi tante volte
dobbiamo essere gli attori le comparse
nel film degli altri io voglio avere voi
dovete avere tutta quanto il film vostro
e allora prendete quando avete finito
ted
prendete
prendete un quaderno a quadretti e
cominciate a intestare i ruoli e
cominciate a mettere gli obiettivi
aiuterete nella vostra borsa voterete
nella vostra ufficio lo guarderete solo
voi ma quello diventerà la vostra road
map della vostra vita cosa succederà
vi sentirete più contenti
avrete un'autostima che sale in maniera
incredibile
non avrete più nessuno che mi dice posso
rubarti cinque minuti perché sapete cosa
dovete fare voi rubargli un altra parte
cinque minuti non è me
avrete avete chiarissimo quello che
dovete fare è anche l'energia vi
arriverà perché state dirigendo verso la
vita che volete voi verso il successo
che volete voi il successo non solo nei
soldi nella notorietà nei tante altre
cose che ci dicono il successo è
l'equilibrio della nostra vita e
prendere in mano la nostra vita e vivere
la vita che vogliamo e questo è molto
importante
quindi se accettate la sfida provate a
scrivere il copione di questo film della
vostra vita provate a diventare gli
attori protagonisti registi della vostra
vita decidete le scene dove girarle
decidete gli attori chi sono e decidete
tutto quello che volete e dovrete solo
ringraziare voi vi auguro una splendida
esistenza una splendida vita
[Applauso]